welcome to Harley's hobbies the Chinna
will be discussed the latest tech news
and delve into the newest tech products
so today we're taking a look at whether
the GTX 1080 Ti or the gtx 1180 is
better and which one you should buy but
before we delve into that make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you guys
like to stay updated with the latest
techniques related to gaming and pcs so
as you guys already know the gtx 980ti
is invidious a flagship for the
mainstream platform for over a year now
it is an absolute monster with 3584 cuda
cores and 11 gigabytes of gddr5 X memory
and they can absolutely crush 1080p
gaming triple Mon or 1080p gaming ultra
wide gaming and pretty much everything
and it can even produce a solid 60
frames per second in most if not all
modern games at flow settings at 4k
however this card has been out for over
a year now and the 10 series itself has
been out for over two years
so anticipation has started to rise for
the next series of GPUs from Nvidia we
were all hoping that Nvidia would give
us some news about the 1100 series at
GDC or at least Computex
however mr. Jensen Huang the CEO of
Nvidia actually asserted that the next
series of GPUs from Nvidia won't be
coming out for a long time from now if
you guys are interested in my breakdown
of what I think mr. Huang statement
means they make sure you check out my
dedicated video on it but long story
short even though mr. Hong said that the
next series of generation of GPUs from
Nvidia is definitely coming out within
the next 12 months so if you don't need
an upgrade right now and you can hold
out for a couple of months then should
you wait for the gtx 1180 and buy that
instead the gtx 1080 TI right now so
first let's take a look at the specs of
the gtx 1180 now these are all rumors
and just leaks so make sure to keep that
in mind but what all these rumors and
leaks are suggesting is that the gtx
1180 will pretty much have identical
performance to the gtx 980ti
as far as cuda cores and that type of
stuff however on top of that it will
have g DDR 6 memory and B anatole
nanometer passes so basically
gtex lemon ad will be a gtx 980ti just
with judy dr6 memory and beyond the
tornado meter process again if you want
all the rumors leaks and specs of the
gtx 1180 then make sure check out my
dedicated video on it suspects are great
and all but how will those improvements
really affect the day-to-day real-world
performance so starting off gt-r six
memory is a lot faster than gddr5 X
memory with its data rates being 16
gigabytes a second instead of tall
gigabytes a second on the gddr5 X memory
so nice 33% increase however this won't
nearly produce a 33% increase in at
frames per second on graphics cards a
much more reasonable estimate would be a
nice 10 to 15 frames per second as for
the 12 nanometer process that will
probably boost the gtx 1180 over the gtx
980ti
by about 10 frames per second again so
considering all that the gtx 1180 should
across-the-board beat the gtx 980ti by
about 20 frames per second so are those
20 frames worth the price and especially
worth the wait so how much will the gtx
1180 cost compared with the gtx 980ti
well here's the good news the gtx 1180
is actually expected to come out for the
same MSRP as the gtx 980ti
and GTX 1080 at $700 now what's even
better is that if you guys remember way
back when the GTX 980 came out the
third-party variants were actually $100
cheaper at $600 so we may see that same
phenomenon with the gtx 1180 with its
third-party variants costing 600 of $700
so that'll save you guys extra hundred
dollars right there so from a price
standpoint the gtx 1180 has a clear win
over the gtx 1080i Vixen provides more
performance while cost meaning the same
amount or even less so really the main
concern over the gtx 1180 is is it worth
to wait until its release state so when
exactly is the gtx lemonade coming out
in the first place well there were a lot
of rumors suggesting that the gtx 980
and 1170 will come out at August
based on how sk hynix the memory
producer for nvidia planned to start
their duty dr6 memory production
at the beginning of summer however based
on mr. Jensen Long's recent comments
that probably won't be true anymore
so a much more reasonable estimate would
be in a fall of this year or at the
beginning of 2019 I really doubt that
Nvidia would want to miss out on the
holiday season of 2018 so I think that
Nvidia may come out with the GTX 1100
series in October so that they can catch
all the sales of the holiday season
however at the same time Nvidia is
completely dominating the market and
there really is no competition forcing
Nvidia to launch the next series of GPUs
so they may just wait till 2019 and see
yes before launching a new 1100 series
they're planning to reveal the next
architecture at the hot chips conference
in August so as a result so I really
believe that the GTX 1100 series will
come up before the March of 2019 and
maybe in October
if envier decides to take advantage of
the holiday season of 2018 so more or
less about a six-month wait so it's the
20 frames per second or those six months
well if you really need an upgrade then
I recommend that you guys just buy the
GTX 1080i because in the performance
upgrade is really pretty negotiable and
the GTX 1080i is still a great card and
will last a very long time however if
you can wait another six months and I
really recommend you guys wait for the
gtx 1180 because it will have a slight
edge over the gtx 980ti and it will also
have a gbbr six memory and it will be on
the new platform so you can take
advantage of all of that as well but
that's just what I think how do you guys
feel do you guys think that it's a
better option to just buy the GTX 1080i
right now or wait for the gtx 1180 make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like this video then make sure
drop a like and hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye
[Music]